[Music]
uh it has been a long 22 months
welcome
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now and now i have
a beard i look like this
um
it's been like i said a long 22 months
um
i'm so glad that this is a talk that we
really get to come back with and and
neil stevenson has been a a very long
time fellow traveler with long now and i
i was reading his books even before i
started with long now 25 years ago
and they're always some of the most
evocative ways to look at the future he
has this kind of amazing prophetic
ability to take a piece of technology
and then push it into
the future and see
the way that's going to affect society
and tonight in in lieu of trying to ruin
this book for you we're actually going
to talk about one of those types of
technologies that is uh in part of the
of this next book we're actually going
to kind of take a look at it from a
scientific point of view that
i think is going to be an interesting
lesson the way we look at thousands of
years in the past and thousands of years
in the future
especially around climate change so
welcome neil stephenson
[Applause]
normally when i do a reading i read from
my own book for obvious reasons
but this time i'm going to try something
different i'm going to quote from some
fascinating books written by other
people
and as i do i'm going to flash the
covers up on the screen to give due
credit to the authors and so that you
can follow up if you want to read more
on your own
in 536 a.d the byzantine historian
procopius was in italy describing a year
without a summer
during the whole year the sun gave forth
its light without brightness like the
moon and it seemed extremely like the
sun in eclipse for the beams it emitted
were not clear like those it usually
makes
john of ephesus reported similar
phenomena in the eastern part of the
empire the sun darkened and stayed
covered with darkness a year and a half
although rays were visible around it for
two or three hours a day they were as if
diseased with the result that fruits did
not reach full ripeness
all the wine had the taste of reject
grapes
john litus a byzantine official posited
a physics-based explanation for the
anomaly the sun becomes dim because the
air is dense from rising moisture as
happened in the course of the recently
passed 14th indiction which is to say
535 and 536
for nearly a whole year
cassiodorus at the same time wrote how
strange it is i ask you to see the sun
but not its usual brightness to gaze on
the moon glory of the night at its full
but shorn of its natural splendor
we are all still observing a sun as blue
as the sea
we marvel at bodies that cast no shadow
at midday and at the force of strongest
heat reduced all the way to the
impotence of extreme mildness and this
is not the brief absence of an eclipse
but as one that has taken place for
nothing short of almost the whole year
we have had a winter without storms a
spring without mildness a summer without
heat
there was no way that these riders could
have known it but the events they were
describing were triggered by two or
three massive volcanic eruptions
elsewhere in the world that all happened
to occur in a span of a few years
beginning around 5 36.
one might have been in iceland another
somewhere in the tropics and one was
definitely at ilopongo in what's now el
salvador
elopongo alone produced 87 cubic
kilometers of ejecta and had devastating
effects on the mayans
at the same time up in scandinavia a
culture was dying out this was a
precursor culture to what we later
called the vikings historians have
debated why this culture waned and
disappeared and there were probably a
number of reasons but it couldn't have
helped that in a part of the world that
was already famous for cold weather and
marginal agriculture they got hit with a
series of incredibly cold winters
no direct accounts survive but the
nordic cultures that arose afterwards
may have preserved some cultural memory
of the event in their stories for them
the end of the world
would come not in fire but in ice a
terrible winter called the thimble
winter or the mighty winter so here's a
passage from the edda
first of all that a winter will come
called fimble winter then snow will
drift from all directions there will
then be great frosts and keen winds the
sun will do no good there will be three
of these winters together and no summer
between
another edict poem the crs's prophecy
states black become the sun's beams in
the summers that follow weather is all
treacherous the sun starts to blacken as
the sun vanishes the stars fall into the
sea
where their heat raises a great steam
that covers the sky
the finnish kalivala contains the
following what wonder blocks out the
moon what fog is in the sun's way that
the moon gleams not at all and the sun
shines not at all
parenthetically i'd be remiss if i
didn't point out what's probably obvious
to all of you which is that these
legends of anomalous long winters that
change the course of human
destiny are of course fundamental to
george r r martin's song of ice and fire
aka game of thrones
doom by neil ferguson catalogued several
post-volcanic winters an eruption in
peru in 1600 was followed by severe
winters in scandinavia and a famine in
russia the 1640 eruption in japan
led not only to cold summers and failed
harvests in its vicinity but droughts in
greece egypt india and other places
after the 1783 eruption of lockheed a
volcano in iceland benjamin franklin
wrote of a constant fog over europe and
parts of north america the mississippi
froze at new orleans and the resulting
food
shortages some historians believe helped
touch off the french revolution
1816 was called the year without a
summer because of the eruption of
tambora in indonesia it and the earlier
lockheed eruption in iceland are
basically tied for the modern record
each put about 110 million tons of
sulfates into the air
the long now foundation owns property
that's home to a number of ancient
bristlecone pine trees
researchers have been able to sample
these and use tree ring analysis to see
how the growth rate varied from year to
year as a result of changes in weather
sometimes the effects are obvious enough
that anyone can just see them by looking
at a slice of the wood but there are
also special staining techniques that
can make the changes more obvious
2036 bce was apparently marked by a
large volcanic eruption that left a
clear discontinuity in the sample on the
left the sample on the right shows a
couple of anomalous years around 1419
bce you can identify them from the blue
fringes in the staining
here's a plot of tree ring data what's
being plotted here is the thickness of
the rings which gives you an idea of
growing conditions
year by year a higher value suggests a
better growing season a low value
suggests that the weather was bad i've
superimposed some vertical red lines
showing the dates of some of the big
eruptions mentioned in neil fergus's
book some of the big drops are
observable in years following some of
the big eruptions notably
lombok indonesia which is the most one
and the one in peru but in other cases
like lockheed
there's not much of a change so this is
kind of interesting
in that you don't always see a strong
one-to-one correlation between these
eruptions these volcanic events and
whether in a particular part of the
world there's a global effect
but those effects are distributed
just because of the complexity of
atmospheric physics here's a similar
chart in the lower part of the chart
you're seeing two plots a bunch of
spikes drawn in black
which are telling you the amount of
volcanic aerosols in the atmosphere so
for example there's a super high spike
in the late 1200s this
group here is probably tambora around
1816. this one here is probably lockheed
and so on and so forth
so
then the blue line is showing how much
the temperature is thought to have
deviated from average and again the
correlations aren't always perfectly one
for one we see a big drop
after tambora
down here but there's other cases where
nothing seems to happen
at the other end of the 19th century
edvard munch painted this famous
masterpiece the dramatic red sky in the
background is open to interpretation of
course but
the painting was made not long after the
eruption of krakatoa which depressed
temperatures all over the world
and created spectacular sunsets like
this one for a couple of years
afterwards
in the 1960s yet another eruption in
indonesia put a plume of ejecta into the
atmosphere the australians got a plane
in the air to take samples when it
landed they noticed a deposit
on the windscreen
one of the australian scientists licked
it
and reported that it was painfully acid
a more sophisticated analysis found
that it was sulfates
sulfuric acid basically
in 1991 when mount pinatubo erupted in
the philippines it was possible to
gather a lot more scientific data beyond
the now familiar
empirical
sensations of depressed global
temperatures and brilliant sunsets this
is all quite well understood when sulfur
dioxide is injected into the
stratosphere it combines with available
water to form sulfuric acid which drifts
around in the form of a very large
number of tiny droplets when such a
droplet is struck by light from the sun
some of the light will bounce back into
space
so it never reaches the troposphere
which is where weather happens and it
can't warm up the planet
some of the light will be deflected
sideways this contributes to a general
brightening of the sky that explains the
beautiful sunsets as well as some of the
mysterious atmospheric phenomena
described by those byzantine and
scandinavian sources as well as benjamin
franklin himself
and some of the light keeps going down
and continues to warm the earth as usual
this keeps happening for a couple of
years which is how long it takes for the
sulfates to wash out of the atmosphere
then everything goes back to normal
sulfates have remarkable leverage
against global temperatures the amount
of sulfates needed to cool down the
earth by one or two degrees simply isn't
that large
it's easy to imagine engineered delivery
systems that would duplicate what
volcanoes have done many times in the
past
high altitude tanker planes high
altitude balloons and big guns have all
been mentioned
this kind of thing goes under the name
solar geoengineering
it's a perfectly well-known concept
among scientists who study these things
but it doesn't get talked about much
because it's controversial
unfortunately the co2 level in the
atmosphere keeps on rising regardless
this is a screen grab
from just a few days ago showing that
the current level is about 414
parts per million
that's up from 411 in the last year the
graph on the lower right
just happens to begin around the time i
was born
and
it shows that just during my lifetime
it's gone from below 320 parts per
million to almost 420.
and if you look at the shape of that
curve not only is it going up which
means that the problem is getting worse
but it's got a little upward curve to it
indicating that the pace at which it's
getting worse is accelerating
prior to the industrial revolution this
number was in the mid 200s today it's
the highest it has been since a few
million years ago
when the world had a completely
different climate
various governments have announced plans
to cut back on carbon dioxide
emissions china for example is saying
that by 2030 their emissions will level
off in other words if they do that and
every other country in the world does
likewise the co2 level will at that
point become a mere linear function of
time it'll still be going up at an
impressive rate but the rate itself
won't be increasing this plot will no
longer have that slight upward curve
it'll just be a straight ramp angling
upwards by something like 2060 or 2070
it's hoped that the world economy might
reach net zero carbon emissions this
doesn't solve the problem it'll turn
this curve into a flat horizontal line
if the co2 level in the atmosphere is
say 500 parts per million in 2070 it'll
remain at 500 until natural processes
can bring it back down again
which is expected to take on the order
of a million years
there are a lot of ways in which this is
bad but perhaps the most serious threat
that we can expect to see materialize in
coming years is that of so-called wet
bulb disasters in which temperature and
humidity both get so high is to make the
survival
of humans a physical impossibility
kim stanley robinson's ministry for the
future opens with a harrowing depiction
of one such event in india
that all sounds pretty bad and like the
kind of thing that a well-ordered
society would mount an effective
response to but we're at the end of
almost two years of a global pandemic in
which a significant fraction of people
refuse to believe in the very existence
of a disease that's killing people
all around them in the hundreds of
thousands
so from all of this it's completely
obvious that the human race is going to
have to build carbon capture
technologies on an incredibly massive
scale
if you think of this in terms of all the
coal mines that have been hollowed out
of the earth's crust all of the
petroleum deposits that have been
drained
all of the forests and peat bogs that
have been burned basically we have to
fill those back up again with stable
carbon
compounds that we'll have to manufacture
we'll need to do it fast
it'll be by far the largest engineering
project in the history of the world
i believe that we will do it and that a
hundred years from now this problem will
have been solved atmospheric co2 levels
will be back to where they were before
the industrial revolution
that's the good news
the bad news is that it's going to take
decades and during that time we're going
to begin seeing disastrous events such
as the one depicted in the ministry for
the future
on those rare occasions when people talk
about solar geoengineering at all it's
conventional to describe it as an idea
that's on the extreme fringe and that
deserves to be there because it seems so
dangerous
much more research is needed is the
usual conclusion
i do wonder whether it will continue to
seem all that dangerous a decade or two
down the road
when climate disasters are leading
directly to mass fatalities
particularly given the fact that nature
has already performed the experiment for
us on several occasions and we know that
the sulfates naturally wash out of the
atmosphere in a couple of years
danger is always relative jumping out of
a moving car is dangerous but people
will do it anyway if the car is about to
go over a cliff
so in my book termination shock an
individual billionaire constructs a
large gun that shoots sulfur into the
stratosphere simulating what volcanoes
do
this is already a fadicam plea at the
beginning of the story and so what it's
mostly about is how people react to it
needless to say not everyone is happy
just to give some sense of scale the
amount of sulfur that this fictional gun
is capable of launching
over the course of a year's continuous
operation is only about one percent of
what mount pinatubo put into the air
explosively but in his mind it's just a
pilot project and the plan is to build
more such facilities in other parts of
the world
and that is the setup for a kind of
geopolitical
uh thriller that is is essentially the
story of those who uh those who are
happy about this plan and those who are
extremely unhappy
so uh with that i think we can shut the
uh projector down and uh and go to the q
a mode thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you i think the um
the setup of the of a rogue billionaire
doing geoengineering is do do you how
likely do you think it is that a
a person will do it versus a government
i think that's a fun way to do the story
it's a fun way to do the story yeah i
think i have to to do some work in the
the story explaining how this guy is
able to get away with it
uh but
having it be an individual um
makes for a kind of better storytelling
um
realistically uh
i i think it would be a pretty hard
caper to to pull off so um
what what i kind of think is more
realistic is that at some point
especially if we start seeing these wet
bulb events or other mass casualty
disasters that some government somewhere
is going to run the numbers on this and
say you know
we don't care what anyone thinks of us
uh this is this is going to be a good
deal for our country
uh and so we're going to go ahead and do
it it's interesting i think that
you're right that at the conclusion of
all these conversations people say we
need to do more research but they're not
really doing it well not only that but a
lot of times when people do try to start
research programs they get shot down
because even doing research
is viewed as being being beyond the pale
yeah even when i think when david keith
spoke here we had about 20 people here
thinking uh that he was
doing that
aerosols in the atmosphere you know for
brain control and yeah and that whole
thing so it quickly goes
sideways yeah yeah they they they're
getting it and they're in a crossfire
from environmentalists on the left
and from people on the right who think
it's all associated with chemtrails
so
and how did you get going down this path
what was their impetus for for starting
down this
um i had been kind of tracking it for
for a while uh
and um you know it's kind of an
inherently interesting science fictional
topic you know the notion of volcanoes
having these these huge effects on human
destiny and particularly the uh
the
what a mystery it was to like the the
romans i mean they had no way of knowing
that a big volcano had blown up in el
salvador right right so to them there's
just something happened
yeah yeah
um
so there's that uh and then i've i've
brushed up against a few people looking
at sort of cloud brightening and other
space-based
solar geo engineering which means
putting stuff at l1 between the earth
and sun
to block some of the sun's light
so it's an idea that's been in the air
for a little while
um
and i just kind of reached a point uh
in 2019 where i thought you know
if not now when uh i'm supposed to be a
guy who writes books about
technical
subjects and you know why why haven't i
tackled this one yet and so if we use
some of these technologies to
potentially
shade the planet there's still other
effects of things like the co2
precipitating into the oceans and it's
just kind of a stop gap absolutely yeah
anyone who studies this at all
will
will admit that right off the bat that
the real problem is the co2 and even if
the the
the warming effects of co2 could be
counteracted
uh through some intervention like this
you'd still have
ocean acidification and other
nasty uh byproducts of of too much co2
in the atmosphere
um
so um so the only way to to to think
about this is as like applying a
tourniquet um you know while the patient
is transported to the hospital
um and you've you've changed your
writing styles over the years you know
going back all the way to your first
there was the command line essay and
then uh with your baroque cycle or are
you have you found a thing that you're
now doing or you continue to do it
changing it for different books
uh it's always a little different um i i
think
there's kind of a
one way of writing things when it's a
kind of contemporary
action you know thriller type of book
like ream d or
or uh or termination shock and then um
uh you know different styles just simply
dovetail with with different uh kinds of
books
i mean i had a lot of fun
sort of copying the
the the sort of
the 17th century english writing style
and the baroque cycle because it's
bombastic and they they capitalize
letters at random and
they italicize things uh
and um
uh and it's just kind of hilarious to
read
and then and also your methodologies
right you i think you started
handwriting back uh at the broke cycle
is that still yeah something you're
doing yeah i'm still still doing that um
uh
there have been a couple books since
then where they that got started on um
uh on a word processor
and um
and so i just kept doing them that way
but for the most part i do all original
composition with fountain pen on paper
so this whole book was written
yeah i i i realized uh
i realized before i uh
just came on stage here that i had
forgotten to post my picture of the
stack which is about
about that high for the manuscript for
this book
and i'm sure uh this is
a slightly painful subject at this point
but with the advent of meta and all that
and and
where where you started with this but
you you have some some thoughts as to
the way this is coming back at you
well it's very weird uh
it's very weird but um the uh
i mean people have been um
sort of uh poking at the idea of the
metaverse since the book came out and
have come up with various
visions of what it could look like and
ways to implement it
and so
but nothing like
facebook
changing its name to meta and announcing
that they're now a metaverse company so
we're followed immediately by uh
microsoft and disney
two other companies you may have heard
of um saying that they too are metaverse
companies
epic is a metaverse card there's a lot
of metaverse companies out there
so
it doesn't doesn't bring me anything
except
you know weird annoying uh
you know contacts on on social media but
um
uh and and probably it probably sells a
few more copies of of snow crash so
that's not all bad but um
i said uh i mean one of the other uh
thing that i work with your daughter and
uh your son-in-law on is the clock
project they've been engineers on the on
the project since since the beginning so
it's been really great uh kind of it's
become a family business yeah and
working with them so it's been really
fun
um
that
i think and on that subject you you sent
in one of the earliest clock ideas when
i i first met you almost 25 years ago
yeah and i wonder if you could ex
talk about that a little bit because i
thought it was one of the more fun ideas
that we played around with and yeah the
ways we're actually doing some version
of it for the for the clock it was um
it was during the run up to uh the the
turn of the millennium and i think long
now wanted to to put the the clock was
still just kind of
just getting started and so
to observe the the
turning over of the odometer at 2000 the
idea was to to put up at least some
visions of what the clock might look
like and so
uh
danny and others asked um a few people
to just sort of draw up their ideas of
what it might look like um
and i had been thinking uh about um
[Music]
about kind of reading the newspaper
every day and
you know getting this constant stream of
information
and
was it really uh was it really that
important to read it every day or
because at the end of the year they
always publish a year end roundup of the
news right and then at the end of the
decade they
they published the you know the the
decade roundup and in uh
at that time they were starting to
prepare their end of century and end of
millennium you know news roundup so you
know the norman conquest and you know
you know all these other things
and um
and so it just got me thinking like what
if you actually structured your life
around that so that you would make a
decision that you were only going to
get an update of the news once a year
or
once every 10 years or whatever and so
uh that produced the idea of monastic
orders that would kind of take a vow to
that effect and they would live in a
set of uh
at the time i drew it as concentric uh
rings with walls
and and gates that would open under
clock power every year or every 10 years
or every hundred or thousand years
um
and when they were open you could pass
through the gate and you could leave if
you wanted or you could go in deeper you
know and become an even more uh isolated
person
so that was the
that was what i sketched out and i think
it's probably still up on the long now
site somewhere
um and then that
became the basis of my novel anathem
with so with a lot of elaboration and
variation
let's see all right from alec v we have
a could vr ar metaverse be used to
simulate the problem and make it feel
more real
um
i'm assuming you mean about uh climate
change and things like that
i think it could be a great display
mechanism to
i mean you can't really get a grip on
what
one of these interventions might do
until you
perform a simulation um and we have got
pretty good software now for uh for for
running climate simulations uh
and um and and seeing how effects are
geographically distributed and and
that's that's kind of the basis of the
book because if you look at one of these
simulations you see
you might see a splotch somewhere in in
in india or africa or or america
where there would be a
severe drought
or or massive flooding
and so that kind of spatial data is
really important
in thinking about these these problems
and these interventions and
and ar vr is a good way to display that
stuff
unfortunately it would only work on
people who already believe in the
existence of human caused climate change
and
anyone else would would dismiss it out
of hand as you know communist propaganda
um
so i'm not sure it would help with that
part of the the problem
and uh peter asks um do you think it's
truly inevitable that we're going to
deploy some of this kind of solar geo
engineering
i wouldn't say anything's inevitable but
um
i think it's under discussed right now
in in our discourse around climate
change um because
it is sort of a taboo
idea
and um
and and and so i i think it it's okay to
bring it out into the open and talk
about it more um
because uh
sooner or later um
again if you read if you read the
opening chapter of kim stanley
robinson's ministry for the future
which is typically for him a
meticulously researched and carefully
drawn
account of one of these disasters
it doesn't take more than one or two of
those to to get a government thinking
about
some kind of intervention
so i do think that um
it's going to get talked about and maybe
going to get done
in in in some parts of the world that
aren't quite so um
um
so meticulous about uh
self
censorship
every night i think it's it's very
interesting how that conversation around
geo engineering creates so much
um
controversy when fundamentally we are
geoengineering the planet and have been
right now for hundreds of years yep it's
it's kind of one of those things it's
also revive and restorers had this issue
of you know if we've been extincting
species right for thousands of years but
the moment you are purposeful in
bringing one back people get they start
using this phrase you know unintended
consequences a lot yeah those though we
can't we can't have those ferrets coming
back yeah
yeah
yeah no it is a an odd um
kind of uh
habit of thought that that we've got
into and i know why it's the it's the
precautionary principle
and the the precautionary principle is
there for good reasons you know we we
screwed a bunch of stuff up
um
but um
but yeah uh
one of the great things about charles
mann's
books 1491 1493 is the completely nuking
the the idea that
that there was a such a thing as
pristine nature
um you know we
even indigenous peoples um
all over the world uh were were
geoengineering their
their ecosystems and their climate for
tens of thousands of years
uh before the first uh settlers even
showed up
yeah so it seems to be fine to do
geoengineering haphazardly but yeah if
we do it with intention then
then we all shouldn't have to have a big
discussion about it
yeah
uh anna marie uh is asking it's
it sounds like you believe that in 100
years we will have successfully
sequestered enough carbon but she's
wondering i think why do you why do you
have so much hope is it just because we
have to because we have to
yeah and um
and i i think once it gets rolling and
we find processes that'll that'll work
that it'll um
it'll become a thing that people are
excited about and that people want to to
take part in
um
and you know we just it's a thing that
has to be done
we have shane asking uh what what what
are you reading these days and do you
read fiction or non-fiction for the most
part i mostly read um
non-fiction i mostly read read history
books um so um
i i did
finally i i postponed
buying and reading the ministry for the
future because i knew it was out there
and i wanted to finish my book
first so so that's definitely
on my my bedside table now and um
for you know as a guilty pleasure i read
the the fantasy novels of joe
abercrombie uh
he's got about nine of those things out
now and they're they're amazingly good
reads um
and then um
a bunch of a bunch of history the some
of the books that i mentioned um
the fate of rome
is a particularly amazing book that's
basically looks at what happened to rome
through the lens of both climate change
and
pandemics
and how those two interacted so
the the part i didn't read about the 536
uh
eruptions and the cold weather that
followed uh is that that cold snap
effectively opened a channel by which
bubonic plague was able to escape from
its reservoir in central asian marmot
colonies and make it out to the
mediterranean
and led to the justinian plague which he
gives a spectacular description of i
mean um
yosenia pestis man that is one
seriously bad
actor and now we don't you know we've
got antibiotics that can control it and
so we kind of underrate it you know
but um it was almost 50 percent of the
known population of the world still yeah
yeah and and and
and in its when it when it really gets
rolling and and just gets
transmitted through the air
you know people would would begin to
experience symptoms and be dead within
an hour or two
just unbelievable
uh bad stuff and
but it's it's bottled up in certain
areas
until the temperature
uh changes in such a way that enables
the vectors of it to to escape so so
that's a great book to read that
children of ash and elm
totally knew history of the vikings is
another one that i
enjoyed very much
nice
um
well
leona's asking if you could share more
about why you find the comancy species
preservation so important but i guess
also
without ruining the part of the book
about this oh well i mean i mean there's
there's a there's some some comanche
related content in in the book um it's
not too much of a spoiler uh it happens
in in west texas
comanche eagle dot org is is ostensibly
a raptor
uh rescue center so like a lot of places
like that you go in and you'll see
eagles and hawks and so on that have
been kept alive who that were shot by a
hunter or something maybe they can't fly
but
they're they're being fed and kept kept
alive uh at this place and they can make
new
you know the parts of them involved in
making new eagles still work uh
so um
so there's that but but these people
also have
are doing a great job of preserving uh
old photos and records and
and i'm gonna use the word artifacts uh
like uh weapons and and other uh items
um
uh
that are um that that tell the the story
of that that people
which is a really interesting and
unusual group of of of people i i won't
try to go any deeper than that but
even among native american
tribes they've got a really unusual
story
and uh
adam is asking what your favorite type
of carbon capture or storage technology
that you're seeing now is
you know um
the tough part is the scale
it has to work on so there's
there's some dialogue in the book where
the tr is saying that the amount of
carbon we have to remove from the
atmosphere if you just turn it into
carbon black and made a pile of it
would be the size of mount rainier
it would be about 30 cubic miles of
solid carbon
and so um
i
remember looking at some an idea i
thought it was cool a few years ago and
you know like we were researching it and
talking about it and you know oh maybe
we should try this and then
actually bothered to run the numbers and
and came to grips with the fact that um
it wasn't big enough i mean there's no
way
as as uh
recently a friend of mine dropped out of
uh jpl to start a carbon capture company
and his comment was we're going to need
a lot of fans
yeah you somehow you have to filter all
of the air in much of the atmosphere
through this device right yeah right
yeah scale is pretty massive
so um
yeah because it's very dilute that's the
problem it's it's all over the world the
uk it's not concentrated anywhere it's
perfectly distributed all over the
the world
and it's um it's not present in high
concentrations it's only only 400 and
some parts per million
so that's a that's a really hard problem
to solve so i i think my favorite
technology hasn't even been invented yet
but but people are working on it hard
i think one of the questions here i
think with with this type of technology
like geoengineering is is how does this
become accepted um in the world i think
one of the interesting things obviously
that science fiction plays this role is
a way of playing something out like this
so that it can then be kind of more
accepted with another generation whether
or not it's it's our generation do you
see you've you've made some efforts in
trying to
make some large positive
uh
versions of science fiction rather than
just dystopic do you
where do you think
where do you think your role is and
other science fiction authors role in in
kind of playing out positive versus
dystopic features
um well i i i think the important thing
is to to um to allow for some some
ambiguity uh and not try to go full
dystopian or or utopian uh because
readers seeing that will i think sense
that oh hang on a sec that's not ever
how it really is
um and so um
what i've tried to do in the case of
termination shock is to you know to to
just show this system being built by
this guy
as kind of the that's the opening that's
uh takes a while to get to it but that's
essentially already happened
at the beginning of the book
and then
rather than trying to portray that as a
dystopian or a utopian
behavior
show how different people respond to it
and so in in this book there are some
people
uh
from low-lying uh areas that are
threatened by sea level rise who think
this is great
because this is going to save their
country
and there's other people who are afraid
that it's going to interrupt the monsoon
that their economy and their way of life
depends on and they are not happy about
it
um
and so i think that's
a fairly realistic depiction of um
of uh of what would happen if somebody
began to do this uh and i think um
the the best way to to to to cover it in
in a
book is to um to show that um and not
try to put put one's thumb on the scale
i'm gonna let stewart have the closing
question um since uh he's he's been
gracious enough to do the sorting here
and he's asking um is is climate change
helping humanity think longer term
oh
well it seems like a great
way to
incentivize that
um
uh
you know um
it's uh
you you can't you can't think about it
unless you're thinking long term because
if you if you're not thinking long term
you're just talking about the weather
um
and so and we've all had the
conversation with the surly uncle at
thanksgiving dinner saying you know
you know uh it was cold last night i
guess that the pro disproves all of this
global warming nonsense um
you know uh and so um
so we kind of have to it's yeah i i
suppose it's a uh
uh
you know a kind of a potentially darwin
award moment for the whole species yeah
in
in a certain way
hopefully we
hopefully we don't win the award
indeed well thank you so much yeah thank
you
thanks y'all
[Music]